you know sometimes i'll have a
photographer who's literally
six inches away from my balls and i can
feel his breath on my balls as he's
taking the photos
and you know he's just trying to do his
job i'm just trying to do mine so but if
you can work with someone who you're
cool with
um it makes that scenario a lot easier
for everyone
[Music]
so i used to work on a building site
that was great
i went to germany for the world cup and
a few friends saw my [ __ ] one day and uh
just sort of made a joke you know that i
should really be doing something that
and
not working on a building site and it
just sparked an idea you know that
someone somewhere was a porn star and
maybe
i could give it a go um so i started
just going to a few like swinging clubs
and things like that just to
sort of see if i had the confidence or
the ability to have sex in front of
strangers
i ended up meeting a guy there who paid
me to have sex with his wife
he obviously saw in my face i was amazed
by it and he said i'll give you 150
euros every time you do that and i
just literally was like let's let's go
again um
it was at 18 yeah i was 18 so i could
just keep going so
so how did you go from that experience
of to actually entering the
industry there was a lot of leg work i
had to sort of you know
prove myself if you were you know
working for a lot of smaller companies
to be able to get an opportunity to work
for a bigger company and
after you sort of worked with the bigger
companies he was able to get a series or
like five scene deal or something and
yeah basically just had to work through
the ranks and uh keep working for the
better companies until i sort of got to
an established part where i am now
talk me through a porn shoot from call
time to rap
what happens so generally on a porn
shoot
everyone will arrive on set we will have
all been
pre-tested for sdi tests and stuff like
that before anyone enters set
once everyone's paperwork's signed off
we're signing the girl we have a full
legal disclaimer and paperwork and
everything that we have to run through
once all that's gone through we'll put
the go into makeup from there we'll
usually then run into the acting where
we go for all the dialogue of the script
and sort of get everything out of the
way up until the sex
at that point we'll break uh prep for
sex where the guys
and girls go and clean themselves and
have some lunch whatever they need to do
before sex
uh and then generally we'll rattle out
the scene uh do sex stills first then
sex video afterwards
the sex stills basically are the photos
of the scene but they definitely help
the performers
just find the flow so rather than just
calling action and two people have got
to go at it
we kind of use the stills to maybe guide
the direction of the scene so we know
what position is going to flow to next
position and
what positions are comfortable or
uncomfortable for certain performers so
the stills definitely help is like a
sort of guideline to the scene uh then
we shoot the outro
and that's pretty much it after that
point there's a little bit more
paperwork at the end
um but that's that's pretty much our day
not as glamorous as everyone might
perceive it to be
certainly not what everyone perceives
yeah most people's perception of porn is
is like a giant orgy or just like a huge
gang bang and just
everyone goes there and has sex and the
cameraman gets involved and after that
he has a go and it couldn't be further
away from the truth
a lot of people might think it's
glamorous and stuff but it it doesn't
always end that way you know sometimes
i'll have a photographer
who's literally six inches away from my
balls and i can feel his breath on my
balls as he's taking the photos
and you know he's just trying to do his
job i'm just trying to do mine so but if
you can work with someone who you're
cool with
um it makes that scenario a lot easier
for everyone
i just feel like it's like it's almost
amazing to have
enough confidence to sleep with someone
in front of like 10 crew members
it's extremely easy to have sex in front
of people
uh it's more in your head to be fair
it's one of them if you
if you're able just to be in the moment
enjoy what you're doing
it doesn't matter what's around you you
know if you have sex in a hotel room you
don't like all the pitchers and stuff on
the wall it's just they're just
around you you know when you're in the
moment the crew are just
they're just paintings on the wall
there's like a fascination about the
adult industry and
do you think it's fair the way that the
media represents the industry
i personally don't think the porn
industry gets portrayed in a very good
light
most documentaries are looking for the
negative story
no one wants to hear how great the porn
star's life is um
my life personally is amazing and
everything
that's amazing about it has come through
adult um
it's changed my life i've been able to
buy homes and look after my family of
course there's
there's some bad eggs but generally most
speaking i've
only dealt with great people and and had
positive experiences
at the end of the day nothing's more
sexier in the footage than a
than a performer enjoying themselves and
having fun like we don't want something
someone to do something they're not
comfortable with or not happy with
what would you say is the biggest cliche
that people think about
when they think of porn fluffers
every single person i've ever met thinks
there's a fluffer
you know just that's job is to get the
guys hard
um nothing could be more further from
the truth if i'm honest
uh it was very eloquently explained to
me once that if you can't get hard for
the girl that we're paying you to [ __ ]
then why would we pay another girl to
suck you off like it just
doesn't make any sense that and just
everyone having an orgy on set
they're just the most two common
misconceptions that people have they
think it's just
a wild party with drugs and hookers or
the it's uh yeah that fluffers are
everywhere just sucking people off so
i kind of wish they were fluffers you
know just that would be great and how
have you found sustaining a relationship
whilst working in the industry it can be
difficult um when i first started out it
was very difficult to find a
relationship
um or keep hold of a relationship you
know you can't be
an idiot to the fact of what you're
doing you know you are having sex with
people
um that is tough to deal with i think if
anyone had to sort of be okay with their
partner there will be some jealousy
there will be some
uh issues you know but um personally
i've been very lucky
my wife's very supportive of my career
before i met my wife
it was difficult you know it's you meet
someone you might get along
you tell them you do porn for a living
this kind of closes the door pretty
quick
does it pay well porn can pay well yep
certainly can uh medium level performer
obviously guys
earn a little bit less than goals um but
you know a thousand pounds a day
someone could easily earn um for a scene
and as i say so it can work out quite
well especially if you've got a good
brand or a good look and you can end up
getting lots of bookings
you know a lot of industries the men
tend to earn higher
um but yeah there's a lot of females
that do generally
straight from the box command a higher
higher rate than
male talent but as you find as you go
through the industry
uh the more desirable male talent the
stronger male talent
uh they catch up pretty quickly to the
female talent because
a good guy is worth his weight in gold
you know
do you have a genre that like you
perform the most i wouldn't say i have a
genre that i perform the most uh most of
my scenes
are sort of me and one girl me and two
girls um but i do
generally like to do the features where
we get to kind of
build a character and kind of get to
play
a character for say five scenes and
follow a story based script
normally we just kind of get the
run-of-the-mill acting script whether it
be the plumber or the
pizza guy or whatever so when we do get
a feature and
uh you really get to sink your teeth
into a character i really do enjoy that
because it's
uh it just gives you a bit of a
different challenge to what your normal
day is and you get to
build a character out of nothing and
then sort of follow his journey
throughout the film
one character i really enjoyed playing
was a
character called murphy uh he was a
survivor
of a dystopian world and basically women
sort of ruled the world and petrol and
things like that was like the new
commodities of the world and
uh he was a sort of like uh
an underground cop kind of thing trying
to hunt these baddies and
we had amazing locations and proper
underground tunnels and bases and stuff
like that
so i was an amazing character that i got
to play with um
and i decided that he was an american so
yeah i got to do a silly accent for a
week which was
kind of fun how did you integrate sex
into that sounds like a whole film on
its own
yeah it was it was a whole film on its
own um and there was lots of different
strange elements that we that we bought
into that
um you know it's where it's from a
dystopian world we was able to go
really really out there in in our
styling in our costumes
um for one of the girls i
built her where i got this gas mask and
then
attached the front of a fleshlight to
the mask so she basically had just a
vagina in the
in her gas mask face and then did the
scene
with the gas mask face which looked
really cool but it's like something that
we definitely couldn't put into a normal
a normal adult film so a lot of the time
we'll see something from conventional
stuff that we like the idea of
um you know that happens a lot i've just
saw a clip the other day on youtube from
a haywire fight scene where
a guy and a girl just literally destroy
a hotel room having a fight and i was
like
that would look great as a sex scene
just
two guys beat the crap out of each other
smash everything up and then in the
frozen passion have sex
so yeah inspiration can come from
anywhere i suppose we just look at
different ideas and sort of see how we
can convert that or mold that into our
our industry is there something you can
pinpoint that has changed the industry
at all
uh so i'd definitely say like the
introduction of other platforms
uh there's so many different platforms
now such as only fans many vids all
those types of things where
content creators can upload their own
footage and charge
the end user that's a whole new concept
that kind of wasn't around say 10 years
ago
or five years ago people can upload
content to their own platform
with their phone and charge x amount a
month and hit the consumer directly
and again the type of content that
they're able to produce is a lot
different to the content that has been
accessible for so long you know it's
does feel a lot more personal a lot more
one-on-one with the performer
and i definitely think that's a market
that's that's that has grown
because of that interactiveness as a
porn star director and company owner
what is important to you to do in the
industry to make it better
yeah i think the porn industry is ready
for change the main changes will be to
empower our performers
you know we want girls to feel empowered
in their scenes i want
them to be happy with their performances
and that's something that we're really
big on you know
every morning as i say we like to go for
a full checklist of
everything the performer likes to do
things they don't like to do we have all
crew on set to listen to that just so
that it's
if anyone hears anything or sees
anything that the girl said i'm not
really a fan of that then they can
interject it's
we like everyone to be completely on the
same page
before we start shooting so the there's
no misconceptions you know there'll be
several hand signals given to the guy if
she wants to stop
she can give a hand signal to a member
of crew then cut the scene she can cut
the scene at any point you know it's
it's definitely about just empowering so
that people don't have negative
experiences or so that people feel that
they have a voice on set
in the uk as a porn actor do you feel
accepted
uh yeah for sure i mean plenty of people
recognize me say hello and
applaud my work and um yeah
and as i say i feel accepted to a
certain degree um
is it as applauded as it is in america
certainly not um but yeah that's it's
it's definitely getting better over the
years i've noticed that
you know as a whole society is becoming
a lot more open to
adult entertainment and stuff it's not
as stuffy as it once was but we do
definitely have a little way to go to
catch up on to
the americans is it an industry you
would recommend people getting involved
in
i think it's something you have to be
very aware of what you're getting into
um when you're 18
or whatever age it might seem like a
great fun idea
uh is that going to be are you going to
have that same mentality when you're 33
maybe not um
you know it's a is a difficult decision
something that you definitely need to
know what you're going into um once you
put something on the internet
it's out there it's always out there you
can't
change your mind and that applies to
everything it's not just porn i mean
even like nudes if you send a nude you
can't
take that back no matter how much you
want someone's downloaded it
and it's the same thing for porn you
know people come they'll do the scene
they like it and then they meet someone
and they don't want to do it or they
have children or
you know it definitely has a big impact
on your life and something you just have
to
really be sure that is something that
you want to do has there been any moment
where you've just thought i'm going to
pack us in i can't do this anymore
you know what i've never really
considered it
i love my job i love what i do it's
not about the sex i i literally go to
work and hang out with my friends
every single day i get to create
movies and films and stuff that i just
geek out on all day and i get to play
with fancy cameras and build really cool
things and
yeah it's i couldn't think of anything
else i'd rather do
if anything it's just i always think
about how i can maintain like how can i
keep this
going like i started porn when i was 18
i'm now 33
and i've never had to have a real job as
i say i don't feel like i work a day in
my life
and for me that's that's just the win
i actually thought he was gonna walk off
and i see him look at me
and he he had a fall and now i know what
the fault was
i've got to kill him and he just walked
up to me and he just went
bang bang straight in the air